EIJI KITAMURA: Web
components enable
you to build a great
website through the use
of reusable components.
But what does it take to
build a web component?
My name is Eiji,
and today I'm going
to give you an overview
of template element.
The idea of templating
isn't a new thing.
Starting from server
side, templating
has been a widely used technique
for assigning variables,
conditional behaviors, and
repeated contents inside HTML.
On the browser side,
similar attempts
have been made by various
libraries using JavaScript,
such a Handlebars.js,
Underscore.js, AngularJS,
to name a few.
They all work well,
but approaches
taken by those libraries
may have pitfalls.
In this example, the
template is actually
a div tag, which is
hidden with a bit of CSS.
A downside of this approach
is that the browser
will fetch resources
like this image element
from inside the template, even
if those resources haven't
been used yet.
It's a waste of resources
and performance.
Another technique involves
storing the template content
inside of a script tag.
The downside of this approach
is because this template
will be converted into DOM
elements using inner HTML.
It could introduce a cross
site scripting vulnerability
if an adequate [INAUDIBLE]
check is not performed.
The template element will
solve those programs.
The template allows you to
declare fragments of markup
which are parsed as HTML
but go unused at runtime,
and can be instantiated
later when you need them.
A template element won't
render its contents by itself,
won't fetch any required
resources, including scripts,
styles, or images, and also
won't excuse scripts inside
of itself.
Currently the
template element is
supported in Chrome,
Firefox, and Opera.
Safari is expected to
support it in version 8,
but you guys know that
things change weekly,
so check in on chromestatus.com.
To detect availability
of the template tag,
check if HTML
template element is
available on the window object.
For unsupported browsers,
you can use platform.js,
a collection of web
components polyfills
made available as part
of the polyfill library.
This will automatically
detect availability
of the template element,
and populate if necessary.
It is really simple to add
your own template to HTML.
Just wrap your template
markup with template tag.
This will make
your markup inert,
so if will no longer
render on the page
until you stamp it out.
To stamp out a
template, you need
to write a bit of JavaScript.
By using
document.importNode, you
can create a clone of
the template content.
Note that setting the
second argument as true
makes it a deep copy.
Once you've created
the copy, you
can just append it
wherever you want.
One thing you should note
before moving forward
is that the template itself is
simply a container for markup.
You might expect to have things
like placeholders, repeaters,
or conditionals,
but they are not
a part of template
element standard.
If you want to use
those advanced features,
I recommend you to use
web components frameworks,
such as Polymer or X-Tag.
So this is a template element.
To learn more about
template elements in detail,
make sure to read
the HTML5 Rocks
article, written
by Eric Bidelman.
Thank you for watching.
See you in the next episode.